[Musique]
tous les samedis tous les vendredis
c'était pour ça et puis personne dans
les rues il y a souvent il y a des
poubelles dehors alors il vire toutes
les poubelles à coup de pieds et
j'attends l'air et les mettre sur les
toits des voitures enfin il décroche
toutes les poubelles qui se promènent
partout et puis ils s'en prennent aussi
aux gens qui parlent des fois ça leur
arrive ma foi et des habitants de la rue
naturellement on craintes parce que ils
ont peur ils ont peur naturellement que
ces garnements leur cassent les vitres
par la suite on se demande comment faire
quand on s'adresse naturellement pouvoir
public on ne sait plus à qui s'adresser
la veille que ça arrive à Perret il y
avait un monsieur un déménageur qui est
juste en face et bien qui voulait
prendre son fusil naturellement pour
aller tirer dessus pour parce que
naturellement on sautait sur sa voiture
il a cette voiture tout est ce qu'il y a
un T et c'est sa femme qui l'a retenue
une fois que les commerçants se
réalisent entre eux pour arriver à faire
quelque chose mais quelque chose quoi
comme une milice par exemple on sera
obligé en tout cas ce qui paraît
surprenant c'est qu'il puisse se passer
devant un poste de police des choses qui
sont semblables c'est tout
personnellement je suis absolument pas
favorable à la surveillance policière
mais est-ce que vous êtes favor à la
constitution d'une milice par les gens
qui arrivera de la rue que non que non
que non que non que non avant c'était
les jeunes de la porte devant maintenant
sur les autres il y a des Noirs il y a
des et tout et tous les commerçants du
coin se plaignent c'est le bal que le
weekend qu'on amène pas mal et puis il y
a le club rue de dessin comme amène pas
mal non plus et tout ça ça se réunit
dans la rue de la gaîté ça fait un
bouchon votre établissement est mis en
cause par un certain nombre d'habitants
de la rue de la gaîté qui dit ce sont
des jeunes qui sortent plus ou moins
éméchés de ce dancing et qui font un peu
de pagaille dans la rue qu'avez-vous à
répondre à cela chez nous à l'intérieur
de l'établissement il y a jamais eu
aucun incident on ne peut pas laisser
rentrer n'importe qui c'est pourquoi
nous avons une surveillance accrue et
une des raisons aussi pour lesquelles il
ne s'est jamais rien passé dans notre
établissement qu'est-ce qui attire ces
jeunes qui ont tout je crois dans les 16
17 au maximum 18 ans qu'est-ce qui les
attire rue de la gaîté tout pendant tous
les week-ends la rue de la gaîté
ça c'est une rue que tout le monde
connaît et si je devais faire une
comparaison je pourrais la comparer
peut-être
comme autrefois je dis bien comme
autrefois l'ancienne rue Pigalle oui la
police n'était pas là pour
plutôt dire que la police est arrivée
tardivement mais parce qu'elle a été
prévenu tardivement le message qui nous
a l'air RT et de zéro heure 17 et c'est
le directeur de Bobino qui nous a
signaler l'incident et au moment le
quart de police secours qui se dirige
immédiatement sur place rejoignez de la
rue de la gaîté et bien tout le monde
était parti monsieur Perret peut-être à
l'hôpital pour se soigner et les témoins
eux-mêmes cet été en réalité dans cette
affaire ce qu'il faut bien souligner
certes la présence du petit poste de
police de la rue de la gaîté est un
élément
de donner l'alerte et c'est pour ça que
les moyens pour appeler la police sont
aussi commodes un simple numéro à deux
chiffres sur un appareil téléphonique et
maintenant qu'est-ce que vous comptez
faire rue de la gaieté pour éviter
c'est une implantation de police
peut-être un peu plus serré une police
un peu plus visible pour rassurer les
honnêtement et faire peur peut-être à
certains jeunes
pourrait-on dire qui se sont surtout pas
du quartier mais qui viennent peut-être
de lieu d'autres banlieues parisiennes
et pour rechercher rue de la gaieté des
lieux où on s'amuse la proximité de Bâle
la proximité d'établissement de boissons
qui donnent à cette rue de la gaîté
ainsi que nous savons traditionnellement
un paysage très parisien
[Musique]